اهلا بكم في الحصاد نواصل معكم هذه
التغطيه للاحداث في السودان وفي اهم
مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
مع سرياني هدنه جديده في السودان لمده 24
ساعه
معارك وتركز على مقر القياده العامه للجيش
ومطار الخرطوم والجيش السوداني يقول انه
حسب ما وصفه بالتمرد في جنوب دارفور
وكاميرا الجزيره داخل مطار مرويه ترصده
واثار دمار خلفته خمسه ايام من المواجهات
مع تلاحق التحذيرات الدوليه من تدهور
الوضع الانساني في السودان فرار الاف
السكر من الخرطوم جراء المعارك ومزيد من
المستشفيات يخرج عن الخدمه ومخزونات
المواد الغذائيه تتناقص وانقطاع الكهرباء
والمياه لساعات طويله واللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر تحذر من عواقب وخيمه على
المدنيين بسبب المواجهات المسلحه
البيت الابيض يحمر البرهان واحميد
تيمسوليه حمايه المدنيين والدبلوماسيين
ويطالب بحوار فوري بين الطرفين النزاع
واسرائيل على خط الازمه بطلب امريكي للضغط
من اجل وقف لاطلاق النار والسفارات 15
دوله في الخرطوم تستنكر استمرار القتال
وتدعوا لانهائه دون شروط وتطالب بحمايه
البعثات الدبلوماسيه
قال الناطق الرسمي باسم الجيش السوداني ان
الجيش وافق على هدنه لاربعه وعشرين ساعه
تبدا من الساعه السادسه من مساء اليوم
الاربعاء بالتوقيت المحلي وتنتهي في
السادسه من مساء غد الخميس وكانت قوات
الدعم السريع قد اعلنت موافقتها على هدنه
جديده ايضا لاربع وعشرين ساعه بتوقيت ذاته
وقالت في بيان انها تلتزم بشكل تام بوقف
كامل لاطلاق النار وتامل ان يلتزم الطرف
الاخر وفق تعبيرها
وكانت الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريه تجددت في محيط مطار
الخرطوم ومقر القياده العامه للجيش
واستعملت فيها الاسلحه الثقيله وافاد
مراسل الجزيره بان اشتباكاتنا عنيفه
بالاسلحه الثقيله بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع في محيط القصر الرئاسي وسمع
دوي قصف مستمر وانفجارات وسط الخرطوم في
المنطقه المحيطه بمقر وزاره الدفاع
والمطار الذي جرت معارك وداريه بين
الجانبين للسيطره عليه كما تصاعدت اعمله
دخان كثيف من مواقع الاشتباكات في مركز
الخرطوم واغط الدخان واجزاء من حي حله حمد
بمدينه الخرطوم بحري وهو يقابل القصر
الجمهوري
الى شبكه مراسلين سنبدا بالطاهر المرضي
معنى من جنوب الخرطوم الطاهر المرضي ما
الذي يجري في هذه الساعه في الخرطوم يعني
هل هنالك اي علامات على ان الناس استفادت
من الهدنه الجديده بعد الاتهامات
المتبادله بخرق الهدنه القديمه
يجري الان هدوء هنالك هدوء حزر لا نسمع
الصوت للاشتباكات لا ندري اذا كانت هذا
احترام للهدنه او ان الليل هو الذي فرض
هذه الهدنه بطبيعه الحال لكن في المقابل
هنالك قلق وعدم امن بالنسبه لي يعني
عصابات في الطرق الرئيسيه في النهب وغير
ذلك لغياب ايضا الشرطه والجهات التي
تستطيع ان تفرض الامن بالنسبه للمواطن لكن
بصفه عامه ان الهدوء هذا يامل كثير من
السودانيين ان يستفيد منه غدا باعتبار ان
هذه الهدنه يستطيع فيها المواطن ان يرتب
اوضاعه وان يستطيع ان يجلب كثير من
الاغراض المتعلقه بالمواد الغذائيه
بالكهرباء بالماء وكذلك هنالك المئات او
بل الالاف من المواطنين المواطنين يريدون
من هذه العاصمه التي يرون انها اصبحت
طارده بسبب انعدام الامن بسبب عدم الرؤيه
واضحه اذا كان هذه الاشتباكات ستتوقف ام
لا ليس هنالك من قياده الجيش او من قياده
قوات الدعم بان هنالك فرصه يمكن ان تكون
صالحه لوقف القتال بشكل دائم والدخول في
حوار هنالك ضبابيه في مستقبل الاوضاع هنا
بالنسبه للجانب العسكري والجن بالنسبه
للجانب السياسي وبالتالي اصبح المواطن قلق
في هذا الجانب القلقي يزداد ايضا فيما
يقتص
بالاوضاع الانسانيه المستشفيات التي خرجت
عن الخدمه عدم فتح مسارات امنه يعني انغاز
او اسعاف المصابين عدم القدره على التحرك
دون ان تكون هنالك يعني
[موسيقى]
استثناءات يمكن ان تؤدي الى كوارث اكبر اي
بمعنى ان جيش وقوات الدعم السريع تقول
انهم ملتزمون بهذه
الملتزمون بهذه الهدنه ولكن يقولون ان هذا
لا يلغي حق الرد اذا ما تجاوز اي طرف من
الاطراف هذه الهدنه وسمعنا بالامس انهم
تبادل الاتهامات بان اي طلب في اتهم الاخر
بانه هو الذي خلق الهدنه شكرا جزيلا لك
الطاهر المرضي من جنوب الخرطوم هيثم معنا
من مكتبنا من الخرطوم ايضا
مناطق للشبكات اليوم
وفي الساعات الماضيه اين تركزت وكيف كان
اثرها على الناس
نعم لدينا الاشتباكات اليوم كانت في منذ
ساعات الاولى
تركزت في منطقه محيط المطار مطار الخرطوم
ومحيط القياده العامه للجيش وكذلك محيط
القصر الرئاسي هذه الاشتباكات استمرت
لساعات طويله لفترات النهار حتى مساء
اليوم وحتى عندما دخلت الهدنه الجديده حيز
التنفيذ في الساعه الاولى كانت هناك ما
تزال بعض الاشتباكات مستمره وكان هناك
ايضا قص في جوي مستمر ولكن بعد ذلك هداه
الاوضاع قليلا والان يسود نوع من الهدوء
ولكن رغم هذا الهدوء نسمع بين الحين
والاخر الدوي انفجارات فيما يبدو لقذائف
او مدفعيه ثقيله على ما يبدو قبل دقائق
اكثر من خمسه او سته انفجارات سمعناها في
مناطق متفرقه ولكن
الاشتباكات المستمره القويه التي كانت
تدور في ساحه خاصه تخوم القصر الرئاسي ما
يعني ان هذه الهدنه وان بدت يعني بشكل اقل
يعني درجه من المرات الماضيه من
الاشتباكات ولكن الان في هذا المساء وفي
هذا الليل لا يستطيع
المدنيين والسكان الاستفاده من هذه الهدنه
باعتبار ان الخوف والقلق ما يزال يعني
يتوجس او يسيطر على الجميع جراء
التخوف من تجدد هذه الاشتباكات في اي لحظه
عموما ربما في اذا ما استمرت حتى ساعات
الصباح هذه الهدنه من غير اي اشتباكات
ربما تكون هي سانحه لعوده جزء من الحياه
ولو بشكل بسيط لتدارب الاثار الانسانيه
الكبيره التي خلفتها هذه الاشتباكات من
مكتبنا في الخرطوم هيثم مراسل الجزيره
شكرا جزيلا لك ونتحول الى مروي شمال
السودان واسامه سيدي احمد براسل الجزيره
وقد تمكنت كاميرا الجزيره بصحبه اسامه من
الدخول الى مطار مروي اليوم لرصد ما جرى
في اهم ما لاحظته اسامه شاهدنا التقرير
والدمار الذي حدث فيه لكن ماذا عن
الطائرات هل سمح لكم بمعرفه عدد الطائرات
الموجوده التي تدمرت
وان كان اي شيء منها بحوزه القوات الجيش
السوداني
زين للمره الاولى منذ بدايه الاشتباكات
بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
هنا في منطقه مروي تحديدا في محيط مطار
مروي وداخل المطار المطار طبعا يعني قد
كان مسرحا لمواجهات عنيفه
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
فيما يبدو ان
قبل يومين كانت هناك معركه كبيره بين
الجانبين استخدمت فيها تقريبا كل الاسلحه
ما بين الخفيفه والمتوسطه والثقيله كذلك
كان مسرحا مع لمواجهات عنيفه يعني لاحظنا
ان المطار شهد دمارا كبيرا بحجم كبير
للغايه
تحدثنا مع مصادر عسكريه بان هناك كثير من
يعني من الوقت وكثير من الجهد حتى تستعيد
حتى يستعيد مطار مروي الدولي عافيته ويعود
للعمل
وتعود الملاحه فيه بشكل طبيعي هذه مهمه
ربما تكون عسيره للغايه في هذه في هذه
الظروف لان المواجهات كانت ليست سهله
بالنسبه لمصادر الجيش بان هناك
جيوب ما سمتها بجيوب المتمردين هنا وهناك
تقوم القوات المسلحه السودانيه
بمطاردتها في عده جهات طبعا
سبقت السيطره السيطره الجيش على مطار مروي
عده طلعات جويه من سلاح الجو السوداني
الذي قام بعمليات استطلاع خلال الامس
والامس الاول ثم قام بقصف اهداف لقوات
الدعم السريع بعد ان قال الجيش انه اجبر
قوات الدعم الس الانسحاب لجهه الجنوب حتى
منطقه الملتقى التي تبعد نحو مئه كيلومتر
جنوب منطقه مروي ومحيط مطار مروي الدولي
عند نقطه الملتقى ومنطقه تحديدا في هذه
المنطقه
واجهه
ارتال من السيارات
والجنود التابعين لقوات الدعم السريع يعني
النيران
للطائره الحربيه سودانيه قامت بحسب مصادر
الجيش بانها قد كبدت هذه القوات المنسحبه
خسائر كبيره وفادحه
وهناك لاحظنا ان داخل المطار مطار مروي
الدولي ان حجم الدمار كبير والاضرار
القسيمه للغايه خاصه وان هناك اتهامات من
قبل الجيش السوداني بان قوات الدعم السريع
قبل ان تنفذ يعني انسح ابها من مطار مروي
انها قد قامت
بفعل
احداث اضرار جسيمه
وتعمدت الاضرار
شكرا جزيلا لك اسامه سيد احمد من مروي
الشمال السودان ونعرض الان للتقرير الذي
حصلت فيه الجزيره لاول مره على الصور
حصريه لحجم الدمار ومجريات ما جرى من هذه
المعركه داخل مطار مروراوي شمال السودان
نحن داخل مطار مروي الدولي هذا المطار
الذي شهد اشتباكات عنيفه ما بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني من خلف
مباشره هذا هو برج المراقبه الذي تعرض
فيما يبدو الى
اضرار جسيمه نتيجه هذه المواجهات المسلحه
التي شهدها هذا المطار
وخلفت اعداد كبيره من القتلى والجرحى
بطبيعه الحال ولكن لا ندري اعداد هؤلاء
القتلى والجرحى بطبيعه الحال هذه طبعا كل
تفاصيل البنايات الملحقه بهذا المطار
اصابها الضرر بشكل كبير خاصه كثير من
المركبات العسكريه اصابها الضرر كان هناك
جنود كثيرون يعني يتقاتلون في هذه الساحه
كل تفاصيل المشهد يشير الى ان المكان قد
شهد يعني اشتباكات
عنيفه استخدمت فيها كل الاسلحه تقريبا بكل
انواعها وجود العناصر التي
تنتمي الى الجيش السوداني بهذه الكثافه
وهذا الانفجار داخل
المطاط
باعتبار انه المطار الثاني الذي حددته
السلطات الطيران المدني بانه المطار
الثاني في الدوله
ويحوي باضافه الى مطار
مطار مدني هناك ايضا قاعده عسكريه تلاحظون
حجم الدمار هذا هو هذه اسوار
زجاجيه لاحدى الصالات هذه الصاله المغادره
ربما ما حدث هنا
يشير الى ان ما حدث لم يكن سهلا
رسم ملامح واقع جديد على هذا المكان قال
الجيش السوداني ان القوات الدعم السريع
قبل ان ننسحب عمدت على تدمير البنى
التحتيه بالنسبه للمطار حسب يعني اتهامات
للناطق الرسمي باسم الجيش
من الخرطوم حافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل
السياسيه استاذ حافظ اهلا وسهلا بك
هذه الهدنه الثانيه في 48 ساعه الهدنه
الاولى الجميع يقول انها اخترقت وفشلت ولم
تصمت ما توقعك للهدنه الثانيه
تحيه طيبه لك وللمشاهدين الكرام وانا
اعتقد حتى الان
يعني بحكم المشاهداته ومراقبتي للاوضاع
هناك الالتزام افضل من الهدنه الاولى هناك
يعني جهود ايضا دبلوماسيه ودوليه جعلت من
الالتزام هذه المره افضل من الالتزام
السابق هناك
اتصالات
وتفاهمات تمت لخلاء
الجنود المصريين وهذا يقتطفون بالطبع ايضا
تم ذلك بشكل جيد ووصل الجنود المصريين الى
الى بلادهم اعتقد ان هذا كله بفضل الجهود
الدوليه والاتصالات
والتفاهمات التي تمت خلال الايام الماضيه
ربما جائعه المناخ وجعلت من فرص الالتزام
بهذه الهدنه فرصه الاولى وبالتالي الاطراف
جميعها لديها مصالح ومصلحه كبيره في
الهدنه تحتاج الى ترتيب اوضاعها من جديد
ايضا الى اجراء مزيد من المشاورات
والاتصالات
وتقييم ما جرى هذا لفتره الماضيه
المرحله المقبله التي اعتقد ان الفرصه
امامها نحو الوقف اطلاق النار نحو التواصل
والتفاوض هي افضل ومتاح الان ومهيا لها
المناخ بشكل افضل من اللحظه الاولى هي
التي هي لحظه الصدمه التي يدعى كل الطرف
بشكل يعني جدي لاحداث اكبر ضرر بالطرف
الاخر او هزيمته وهذا امر لم يتحقق خلال
الفتره الماضيه وبالتالي تجد ان الفرص
الان متاحه امام خيارات اخرى غير غير
الخيار الصفري الذي كانت تنتهي الاطراف
خلال فتره الماضيه
وهل هل هل هذا يعني انك ترى ان الاثنين
الان الاطراف الطرفين يدركان انهما لن
يستطيع التخلص من الاخر هل هذا هو ادراك
مثلا قوات الدعم السريع مثلا على سبيل
المثال
بالطبع يعني
الحاق هزيمه ساحقه يعني لا يستطيع احد
تحقيق اهدافه التي ذكرها لكنها تبدو اهداف
يستطيع ان يتحدث لكن حقيقه الواقع تقول
غير ذلك
خمسه ايام حتى الان
والاشتباكات مستمره استخدم فيها كل مع
الاسلحه واستخدم يعني حتى الطيران
والمدفعيه الثقيله لكنها على الارض لم
تغير كثيرا في النتائج ولم تحقق الاهداف
التي يريدها كل طرف التالي
هذا الخيار الاخر هو خيار واقعي الخيار
المتاح وليس وليس خيار الاطراف انما اي
عمليه لديها عدد من الاهداف او لديها يعني
خيارات خطط بديله فيما لم تستطيع اذا لم
تستطيع تحقيق الهدف الاول الذي تعلنت عنه
فهي تذهب الى تذهب الى تحقيق اهد افها من
خلال وسائل اخرى اشكرك شكرا جزيلا من
الخرطوم حافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
نقلت صحيفه عن مصادر مطلعه قولها ان
اللواء الليبي المتقاعد خليفه حفتر ارسل
طائره واحده على الاقل يوم الاثنين لنقل
امدادات عسكريه لقوات الدعم السريع في
السودان ضمن المواجهات الحاليه مع الجيش
السوداني
واضافه انه لا توجد مؤشرات في الوقت
الحالي على ان التدخل حفتر في السودان كان
بدعم من روسيا او الامارات وافادت مصادر
الصحيفه بان مصر ايضا ارسلت طائرات حربيه
وطيارين لدعم الجيش السوداني في ذات الوقت
الذي ارسل حفتر مساعدته لقوات الدعم
السريع وكتبت هول ستروع قوى خارجيه في
الصراع يزيد من خطر التصعيد في القتال
ويمكن ان يقوض جهود الولايات المتحده
والامم المتحده وغيرهما للتوسط في وقف
اطلاق النار
وفي هذه الاجواء ما زالت قوات الفريقين
البرهان وحميدتي تشتبك في عده نقاط على
امتداد خارطه السودان رغم تفوق الجيش
السوداني في العدد والعتاد فان قوات الدعم
السريع تتفوق في خفه الحركه وسرعه
الانتشار وهو ما يتضح في مناطق توزيع قوات
الطرفين
فرق كبير في القدرات العسكريه وطبيعه
الوظائف بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع لكن الطبيعه المعركه وجغرافيه
المواقع التي سيتم فيها حسم المعركه
تقلصان هذه الفوارق عناصر قوه الجيش
السوداني من طائرات واسلحه ثقيله ومدفعيه
يحد من قدراتها ضغط الكثافه السكانيه
العاليه في المناطق المتنازع عليها وحرص
الطرفين على عدم رفع الكلفه البشريه لاي
انتصار المحتمل في اوساط المدنيين
فالمعركه تدور للسيطره على الارض بالسلاح
وعلى الراي العام في الوقت نفسه ويعد
الجيش السوداني اكثر عددا وعتادا وانتشارا
وابرز مناطق انتشاره في العاصمه هي
القياده العامه التي توجد قرب القصر
الجمهوري وغير بعيده عن مطار الخرطوم
الدولي بالاضافه الى معسكر سلاح المهندسين
ومحطه المياه اما خارج العاصمه فلل الجيش
معسكرات للقوات البريه وقواعد جويه عده
ابرزها قاعده كورس الجويه
في ولايه النيل الابيض وفيها تعسكر وحدات
من القوات الخاصه في الجيش السوداني قاعده
الفاشر الجويه وتقع في ولايه شمال دارفور
وتعد احد ابرز المعسكرات الكبيره في
المنطقه قاعده الجويه وتوجد في جنوب
كردفان بالاضافه الى مطار الابيض ويقع في
ولايه شمال كردفان ويضم قاعده للدفاع
الجوي والقوات الخاصه
بالاضافه الى مطار قاعده شندي الجويه
وتوجد في ولايه نهر النيل وتضم وحدات
مختلفه من الجيش السوداني ومطار مروي شمال
العاصمه حيث توجد الى جانبه قاعده جويه
للجيش وفيها بدات تصعيد الحالي اما قوات
الدعم السريع فقد كانت قبل الاقتتال
الحالي متمركزه في المناطق الحدوديه
والولايات التي تعاني من اضطرابات امنيه
ومن بين المناطق التي كانت وما تزال تنتشر
فيها
وولايه النيل الابيض والنيل الازرق
والجدارف اما في الخرطوم فخلال السنوات
الماضيه كثفت قوات الدعم السريع من وجودها
في مثلث مدن العاصمه ومنطقه الخرطوم
الكبرى مع تنامي نفوذ قائدها محمد حمدان
حميدتي بعد سقوط نظام البشير وبلوغه منصب
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده ودخوله مربع
السلطه المركزيه حيث اخرج جيش السوداني
عدد من مقره ومواقع اخرى لصالح قوات الدعم
السريعه التي حولت هذه المقر الى معسكرات
وقواعد
ومعنا من الخرطوم اللي هو بدر الدين عبد
الحكمه الباحث في الاكاديميه العليا
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه والامنيه ندخل الان
نقترب من اليوم الخامس من هذه المعارك ولا
يوجد حسم القياده العامه
ومقر القصر الجمهوري ومطار الخرطوم ما زال
ما زالت جميعها بين عمليات كاروفر هل بات
واضحا الان لقاده الجيش ان هذه معركه لا
يمكن الحسم فيها
انا اتحدث
بكل صيغه بين القوات المسلحه تم حسمه
المعرفه
متى تماما
المعركه حتما تماما لا عده اولا القوات
الدعم السريع تفككت
وعجزت عن جمع اطرافه الان
اليات الصغيره
بهذا الشكل لماذا لا نرى السيد البرهان في
الخرطوم يعلن ليبشر السودانيين بان
المعركه انتهت وان الدعم السريع قد هزم
انا ما بتحدث فيه انه المعركه انتهت فقط
لكن
في بدايه هذه العمليات كانت يعني تهاجم
هذه القوات باعداد كبيره من العربات
الرباعيه وبحمازه عالي الان
الهجوم بعشرين وثلاثين عربيه يعني اخر
معركه اليوم كان دمرت خالص في الشرق
المطار دمرت خالص
النجوم وغمض على قائد هذا الهجوم واستلمت
القوات المسلحه عشرين عربيه ودمرت عدد من
العربات وهربت باغيه العربات
اذا كان لحالها هكذا لماذا يستجيب السيد
البرهان
للدعوات الدوليه
بهذه الهدنه الجديده وربما تمتد هذه
الهدنه وهنالك تداخل اسرائيلي حسب اكسس
موقع اسيا اكسس الامريكي
واتصالات لماذا لماذا يستجيب لمثل هذه
الدعوات اذا كانت المعركه محسومه وهو قادر
على حسمها في غضون الساعات المقبله مثلا
شهاده الامريكي وفوق كر نفسه
الاقتصاد مع غياده غياده هذه
يعني عدد من التي توصل
تواصلكر تحدث عن فقد الاتصال بالجميع ليس
بفئه دون فئه اينما تحدث في مجلس الامن
اذا فقط الاتصال هذا يعني انه لا يوجد
غياب وسيطره لا يوجد غياض السيطره هذا
يعني يعني فقره اهدافهم التي يقاتلون
فقدوا انه يتواجد في موقع واحد هذه هزيمه
الان القوات المسلحه تتحدث عن
الخرطوم
متخصصه في عمليات المدن هي فرق من من فرق
مختلفه من
جبال النوبه من الشرق ومن الشمال دخل
والان يمكن هذه الفرقان الهجانه هم الذين
يحدثوا خسائر هذا اليوم في شرق المطار
خسائر فادحه والقبضه على غايه هذه القوه
انا بعتقد اذا واذا بدات هذه العمليات
لانه هؤلاء لا يلتزمون في اي وقت لانه
اصلا ناتج السيطره لهم الان شكرا
للاسف انتهى وقتنا اللواء بدر الدين عبد
الحكم الباحث في الاكاديميه العليا
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه والامنيه ضيفنا من
الخرطوم
ومن الخرطوم ايضا ينضم الينا فيصل محمد
صالح وزير الاعلام السوداني السابق استاذ
فيصل اهلا وسهلا وشكرا على حضورك معنا ما
هو تقييمكم لمرحبا ما جرى في الايام
الخمسه الماضيه
الوضع الحقيقه معقد جدا من الواضح جدا انه
يعني احد الاطراف او على الاقل للطرف
الحكومي كان يظن انه سينهي هذه المعركه
المفاجئه في فتره قصيره جدا وهذا
السيناريو مع الاسف لم يتحقق ولا يبدو انه
قابل للتحق الان نحن اعتقد في حاله من
الفوضى الشامله هناك وجود لدعم السريع
للقوات المسلحه في مناطق مشتركه في وسط
العاصمه سواء كان في مطار الخرطوم في
القياده العامه في القصر الجمهوري في
المناطق الاستراديه داخل مثلث العاصمه
الصغير ثم بعد ذلك هناك ايضا انتشار
للقوتين في اماكن مختلفه من العاصمه وفي
احياء مختلفه لا يستطيع احد من الاطراف ان
يدعي انه يسيطر تماما ولهذا نحن نعيش حاله
كما ذكرت من الفوضى هناك
ازمه انسانيه حقيقيه هناك معظم المستشفيات
لا تعمل طرق المواصلات متوقفه الامدادات
الامدادات الماء والكهرباء مقطوعه عن معظم
مناطق العاصمه وهناك اشكاليه في اصلاح
الاعطال ليست هناك حد يعني خدمه اسعاف
لايصال المرضي الى المستشفيات معظم
المستشفيات خرجت من الخدمه بالاضافه لانه
حالات التجدد القصف في مناطق حتى في
المناطق السكنيه المنطقه التي اسكن فيها
الخرطوم بحري في كوبر تعاني من المساله
القصف حتى خلال فتره الهدنه التي يعلنت
نعيش حاله من الفوضى
الشامله بما انك ذكرت ان القوات المسلحه
والطرف الحكومي كان تقديرها انه سينهي
المعركه بسرعه يعني هل هل تقول كما يقول
البعض انه
الحكومه او الجيش هو من بدا هذه المعركه
انا لا اعلم حقيقه التفسير الدقيق لكن كان
هناك توتر وكان هناك استعداد للجانبين كان
من الواضح خلال الايام الاخيره انهما
سيدخلان في معركه لكن بالتحديد من اطلع
الرصاصه الاولى لا اعلم لكن كل الطرفين
كانوا جاهزين
اعتقد انه
كان لديه صور بانهي هذه المعركه بسرعه
شديده جدا وهذا لم يحدث القوه السياسيه
اين هي خصوصا انه اعلن من جانب متحدثين
باسم المخابرات السودانيه انه هذه معركه
ليس فيها حياد لابد ان تكون مع هذا او مع
ذاك اين هي القوه السياسيه
انا اعتقد انه القوه المدنيه والسياسيه
تحدثت موقفا خلال الاحاديث مطوله حول بيان
مشترك ضمن معظم القوى السياسيه حتى التي
كانت مختلفه وخارج الحريه والتغيير هم ضد
الحرب وهذا ليس موقفا محايدا بمعنى انه
الموقف المحايد ممكن يكون شخص غير معني
بما يحدث في البلد هذا ليس صحيح القوه
المدنيه والسياسيه ضد الحرب وهذا موقف
ايجابي وهي تعتقد بانه لن احد هذه المعركه
وان الخاطر هو الوطن والمواطنين وهذا ايضا
موقفي ايجابي شكرا لسنا مضطرين ان نقول
اننا نقف في الجانب الفلاني او في الجانب
الفلاني القوه المدنيه والسياسيه هي اول
من دعا الى جيش قومي موحد بعقيده وطنيه
القوه المدنيه والسياسيه هي اول من دعى
يحل كل الميليشيات بما فيها الدعم السريع
ودراسه دمجها في القوات المسلحه السودانيه
هذا منذ اليوم الاول اربع سنوات
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
للاسف وزير الاعلام السوداني السابق من
الخرطوم
ومن مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك ينضم
الينا فرحان حق النائب المتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده يوم خامس
او شكلنا على دخول يوم خامس من الاشتباكات
وهدنا اولى قال الجميع انها اخترقت ونحن
في هدنه ثانيه ما هو توقعكم لهذه الهدنه
القائمه حاليا
ان نرى ان يكون هناك هدنه فعليه ومستمره
لاسيماهن يحترمها الاطراف للاسف فراى اين
الكثير من المواجهات المستمره بالرغم من
اعلان وقف اطلاق النار ولكننا نعمل من اجل
ان نرى ان كنا سنتوصل الى وقف اطلاق نار
يستمر على الاقل 24 ساعه لوصول المساعدات
الانسانيه والحصول الناس على المساعدات
الطبيه اذا كانوا بحاجه اليها
ونوع من
المساحه لكي يتنفسوا هذا هو وهذه هي
نوايانا الاولى ولكن نحن بحاجه الى وقف
الاعتداءات واليوم الخميس هذا ما سيناقشه
الامين العام غوتيرش مع رؤساء الاتحاد
الافريقي وجميع الدول العربيه وكذلك منظمه
الايجاد الهيئه الحكوميه للتنميه من اجل
تنسيق هذه الجهود
للتوصل الى خفض التصعيد وانهاء هذه
المواجهات بطريقه دائمه بالنسبه للمبعوث
الامم المتحده في السودان السيد فولكر
ما الذي يفعله الان ما هو الدور الذي يقوم
به
يتحدث الى الطرفين من طرف الجنرال البرهان
ومن طرف
الجنرالو في محاوله للتوصل الى وقف لاطلاق
النار لمده 24 ساعه يتم احترامه ومن ثم
ابعد من ذلك نحاول ان نصل الى وقف
للمواجهات لفتره اطول وفتره اطول منخفض
التصعيد من اجل انهائي هذا القتال الفاضي
الذي شهدناه لمده خمسه ايام اليوم
كان متحدث هنا
قارن الطرفين لا يرغبان في الاحتكام الى
الحوار وانما الى السلاح هل هذا هو
تقييمكم ايضا ان الطرفين غير جاهزين
للحوار
ممثلنا
ممثلنا قال في بدايه
هذا العمل منذ يومين انه في تلك اللحظه
كان واضحا ان ليس هناك اي من الطرفين
مساعد
لوقف المواجهات والعمل على اساء السلام
هذا يجب ان يتغير ونحاول ان نستخدم كافه
التاثيرات من دول المنطقه وغيرها لاقناعي
القائدين من اجل وقفي اي
اجراءات عسكريه اضافيه لانها كانت مدمره
اكثر او هناك المئات من المدنيين الذين
جرحوا وقتلوا حفت
ان طائره حربيه من جانب اللواء المتقاعد
خليفه حفتر في ليبيا حطت في السودان محمله
باسلحه وذخيره لقوات الدعم السريع وان
ايضا طائرات مصريه
وصلت الى السودان لمساعده الجيش السوداني
كيف تعلقون على هذا الخبر
الى كافه دول المنطقه لنرى ما يمكن القيام
به من اجل خفض التصعيد نحن لا نريد المزيد
من العسكره على الارض هناك اصلا عدد كبير
من الاسلحه الموجوده داخل البلاد ونريد ان
نحرس
على الحد منها لانه
في نهايه المطاف فان القائدين
ومناصريهم كلهم وافقوا على عمليه انتقاليه
وافقوا على رسم مسار مستقبليا للسودان
للاسف كل ذلك توقف بسبب هذه الايام
الاخيره من المواجهات ونحن بحاجه الى
العوده الى مسار السلام
اذا صح ما ذكرته عن مساعدات عسكريه مصريه
للجيش السوداني ومساعدات عسكريه من حفتر
في ليبيا لقوات الدعم السريع الى اين ياخذ
هذا الصراع الحالي في السودان
صحه ذلك
يجب
ان نتاكد من هذه المعلومات من خلال الادله
ولكن طبعا نريد ان نتلافى خروج هذه الازمه
عن السيطره واضافه المزيد من الاسلحه
والدقائر يصب الزيت على النار بكل بساطه
ما هو تقديركم لعدد
النازحين او الذين تورطهم الحرب الى
النزوح من
ديارهم من منازلهم في الايام الخمسه
الماضيه لانه مفاوضه اللاجئين تتحدث عن
الاف بالفعل فروا الى دول مجاوره
هناك الكثير من الاشخاص الذين فروا
مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين لديها اشخاص موجودين
على الحدود مع تشاد الذين وهم قد رؤوا بام
العين دخول هؤلاء الاشخاص النازحين
ولكن انا انوه بان ذلك قد يكون رقما اقل
من الرقم الفعلي بالنظر الى كثافه
المواجهات في الايام الاخيره الناس عجزوا
عن الخروج هناك احتمال
بان يهرب المزيد من الاشخاص بعد حين يصير
من الامن ان يخرجوا المقر الاول المتحده
في نيويورك المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده شكرا جزيلا لك
تفقهم المواجهات المسلحه بين الطرفين
النزاع في السودان يفاقم ذلك من معاناه
المدنيين العالقين بين النيران المتحاربين
وزاره الصحه السودانيه قالت ان استمرار
المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم السريع ينذر
بوضع صحي كارثي في البلاد وان القطاع
الصحي في حاله انهيار ومن ناحيه ثانيه
اعلنت نقابه الاطباء السودانيين ان قرابه
60 مستشفى قد توقفت عن العمل او في سبيلها
الى ذلك بسبب هذه المواجهات بينما حذرت
منظمات دوليه من اوضاع انسانيه وصحيه
ماساويه في السودان اذا لم يتوقف القتال
سيذكرون افطارهم هذا
سيذكرون رمضان هذا العام والعيد الذي
سيليه فتلك لحظات خطفها اقتتال اخوه الوطن
لا يخاف المرء هنا على حياته من رصاص
المتقاتلين فحسب فالمواجهات المسلحه جاءت
لتدفع وضعا انسانيا مزريا الى حدود
الكارثه
ينبه برنامج الغذاء العالمي الى ان ما
يقرب ثلث سكان السودان كانوا اساسا يعانون
من الجوع قبل اندلاع الصراع المسلح ويحذر
من اي يؤدي استمرار العنف الى الالقاء
بملايين اخرين في دائره المجاعه
الحقيقه هي انه في الوقت الحالي يكاد يكون
من المستحيل تقديم اي خدمات انسانيه في
الخرطوم وما حولها خلال الايام الاربعه
الماضيه نفذ الماء والغذاء وقننت الكهرباء
في بعض الاماكن قطعت تماما
الى معاناه الناس تلك تضاف محنه الصحه انه
قطاع على شفال انهيار اغليت مشافن بعد
تعرضها للقصف وخرجت عشرات غيرها عن الخدمه
سريعا اطلقت وزاره الصحه السودانيه نداء
استغاثه دعت المتحاربين الى وقف العمليات
المسلحه وتامين المستشفيات والالتزام بفتح
مسارات للاسعاف كما دعت المنظمات الدوليه
لتقديم امدادات طبيه عاجله بانتظار ذلك
تشكو المنشات الصحيه قله حيلتها امام
اعداد المرضى والمصابين بل وحتى جثث قتل
المواجهات وضحايا القصف العشوائي من مهام
لجنه شكلتها وزاره الداخليه السودانيه جمع
تلك الجثث المنتشره في الطرق وحفظها في
المتاح من المشارح ومن مهام اللجنه ايضا
الاشراف على نشر الكوادر الطبيه لكن
ليسعها باي حال ضمان وصول المدنيين الى
المرافق الصحيه
اريد ان اكون واضحا للغايه على جميع
الاطراف ضمان الوصول غير المقيد والامن
الى المرافق الصحيه للمصابين وكل من يحتاج
الى طبيه واحث جميع الاطراف على الاستجابه
للدعوات لوقف اطلاق النار لاسباب
الانسانيه واسكات المدافع والعمل من اجل
حل سلمي يتاخر ذلك الحل فينشد البعض حلا
في الفرار وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه قدرت
عدد النازحين المدنيين في السودان جراء
المعارك بالالاف
سيخلفون ورائهم عالقين كثرا بين نيران
متحاربين هؤلاء من طلبه جامعه الخرطوم ظل
عالقين داخل الجامعه منذ بدء الاشتباكات
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
بداوا بخروجهم اللافت هذا او فرح حظا ممن
تقطعت بهم السبل في ارض المعارك بعضهم
عالق هناك في حي المطار بوسط الخرطوم
قالوا للجزيره انما انهم الغذائيه نفدت
وانهم يخشون من توقف امدادات المياه في اي
لحظه
قال مسؤول بمنظمه قد الطفوله للجزيره ان
تسعه وعشرين مدنيا بينهما اطفال محاصرون
على بعد امتار من القصر في مبنى يضم
مكاتبه وشققا سكنيه اضاف المسؤول ان
المحاصرين يواجهون نقص الماء والغذاء وان
هواتفهم لا تعمل بسبب غياب الكهرباء واشار
المسؤول الى ان معظم المحاصرين من الاجانب
وان منهم مصريين ويابانيين وايرلنديين
والسوريين وامريكيين
الرئيس هو الكيليه روتو تفاقه مع العميد
العامله الامم المتحده انطونيو على ارسال
بعثه الى الخرطوم للقاء طرفي النزاع وحذر
رئيس الكلي من تداعيات القتال في السودان
على امن وسلم المنطقه والعالم باسره وقال
ان هناك خطرا حقيقيا من ان يورط تصاعد
العنف لاعبين خارجيين اقليميين ودوليين ما
يؤدي الى ازمه امنيه وانسانيه ودعى الرئيس
الكيني قاده الطرفين المتحاربين الى
الالتزام بقرار منظمه ايجاد خلال قمتها
الاحد الماضي بما يشمل وقفا فوريا للاعمال
العدائيه والسماح بالعبور الانسانيه غير
المشروط والتعاون الكامل مع مهمه قاده حين
يصلون الى الخرطوم اوضح ان تلبيه هذه
الشروط والانخراط في المحادثات الضروريه
للعوده الى المفاوضات بشان الاتفاق
الايطالي
عبد الوهاب شيخ عبد الصمد رئيس معهد
الدراسات الاستراتيجيه للقرن الافريقي من
اللافت في تصريحات الرئيس الكيني انه تحدث
عن احتمال انخراط اطراف اقليميه ودوليه
اذا استمر الصراع في السودان ما هي
الاطراف الاقليميه والدوليه التي يمكن ان
تنخرط في مثل هذا الصراع
خوف كبير بين القاده الافارقه بالنسبه الى
الوضع في السودان الان السودان
[موسيقى]
موجود في القرن الافريقي وفي منطقه الساحل
ولهذا القاده الافارقه خائفون وقليقون من
هذا الوضع في السودان على وجه الخصوص
الرئيس الكيني يقول
ان الوضع خطير لدرجه ان عددا من القاده
سوف يتوجهون الى البلاد من اجل محاولات
التوسط بين الطرفين المتنازعين لا السودان
يتشارك حدودا مع تشاد و اثيوبيا وجنوب
السودان وايضا هناك مشاكل مماثله في تلك
الدول
ان لم يتم احتواء هذا الوضع في السودان
فهو قد ينسحب ويتطور ويتفاقم ويؤثر على
دول المجاوره لهذا سوف يهرع على قاده
الافارقه من اجل لعب دور الوساطه بين
الاطراف المتنازعه في السودان في السودان
ايضا هناك الكثير من اللاجئين من الدول
المجاوره بالتحديد من اريتريا من اثيوبيا
ومن جنوب السودان اذا هذا سوف يفتح
الباب واسعا امام ازمه انسانيه ازمه
لاجئين ونازحين سوف تؤثر على السودان ماذا
عن الاطراف الدوليه لان الرئيس روتو تحدث
ايضا رئيس الكيني تحدث عن انخراط اطراف
دوليه من هي الاطراف الدوليه التي يمكن ان
تنخرط فعلا في هذا الصراع في السودان
في السودان هو نوع من الحرب الوكاله هناك
الكثير من تضارب المصالح بالنسبه الى
الوضع حاليا هناك عدد من الدول التي
تشارك في تاثير على السودان لاسيما سعوديه
الامارات الولايات المتحده وروسيا ايضا هي
ايضا دول معنيه بهذه المشاكل في السودان
هذا ما يتحدث عنه الرئيس الكيني
كيف يمكن للاطراف الدوليه المؤثره في
النزاع في السودان ان تلعب دورا اذا استمر
هذا النزاع سوف يشكل مشكله للقرن الافريقي
لاسيما من طاقات شرقي افريقيا
عذرا المقاطعه ما هي قدره الافارقه
وهم حتى الان لم يحصلوا على تصريح بالدخول
لا يستطيعون دخول السودان ما هي قدرتهم
على التاثير فيما يجري الولايات المتحده
حينما طلبت من احد ان يتدخل طلبت من
اسرائيل وليس من الاتحاد الافريقي وليست
من كينيا على سبيل المثال
المثال السوداني
اعتقد ان دول المنطقه هي التي يجب اللجوء
اليها قبل اي اطراف دوليه
فهناك دعوه لوقف لاطلاق النار ومن بعد ذلك
سوف تتم معالجه مساله الاطراف الدوليه كيف
يمكننا ان نخفف من التوترات بين هذه
الاطراف المتنازعه القاده الافارقه سوف
يمارسون الضغط على الجنرلين اللذين
يتقاتلان من اجل
تهدئه الوضع اذا نجح هذا الموضوع
وتم وقف اطلاق النار المرحله التاليه تكون
مساله الاطراف الدوليه المشاركه التي يمكن
ان تؤثر السودان في موقع استراتيجي ان لم
تحلل مشكله فيه
فهذا من شانه ان يخلق مشكله انسانيه داخل
المنطقه
وهذا يفتح الباب على مصراعيه امام ازمه
اقليميه
ومشكله وازمه انسانيه
هذه من القضايا التي تؤرق بال القاده
الافارقه
الدول المجاوره ايضا لديها مشاكل مماثله
ومن هنا هذا القلق والخوف اشكرك شكرا
جزيلا من عبد الوهاب الشيخ عبد الصمد رئيس
ومعهد الدراسات الاستراتيجيه للقرض
الافريقي
طلال المتحدث العسكري باسم القوات المسلحه
المصريه انها تؤكد انها تنسق مع جهات
الاختصاص المختلفه في السودان لتامر عوده
كافه عناصر القوات المسلحه المصريه
بالسلام الى مصر وكانت الخارجيه السودانيه
قالت ان العسكريين المصريين الذين احتاجهم
الدعم السريع في مروي كانوا في تدريبات مع
الجيش السوداني
وفي هذه الاثناء تبدو اطراف دوليه مساعيه
مختلفه لحث اطراف الصراع السودانيه على
الحوار التفاصيل في هذا التقرير لاحمد فال
ولد الدين
لليوم الخامس يسكن الدخان السماء الخرطوم
فلا يبدو ان الطرفين المتصارعين انصتا بعد
النداءات الداخل ولا الخارج
واشنطن طالب الطرفي الصراع بالدخول في
حوار فوري ودون تاخير سينيوريوس
الامريكيين على اتصال مباشر مع قياده
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع ونواصل الضغط على الطرفين للتوصل
الى وقف فوري لاطلاق النار وضمان التزام
جميع القوات بذلك الجنرال البرهان
يتحملان مسؤوليه ضمان حمايه المدنيين
السودانيين والاجانب
المفارقه ان اخر النداءات الموجهه الى
عاصمه
تل ابيب هذه المره فقد نقل موقع اكسيوس ان
الامريكيين طلبوا من تل ابيب التواصل مع
جنرالات السودان لطلب التهدئه
على تواصل مستمر بالجنرالين البرهان
وحميتي هذا الحراك الدبلوماسي ياتي بعد ان
اصدرت عده سفارات اجنبيه في الخرطوم بيانا
دعت فيه للتهدئه فقد جاء في البيان
الدبلوماسي ان القاده العسكريين عرضوا
اعدادا هائله من السودانيين للخطر وراء
البيان ان القاده العسكريين عرقلوا سعي
السودانيين المشروع الانتقال الديمقراطي
وحث البيان واطراف الصراع على التقيد
بالتزاماتها الدوليه بحمايه المدنيين
والدبلوماسيين
استمرار المعارك دون افق واضح ضاعف القلق
الدولي فقد اعلنت الامم المتحده ان جلسه
مشتركه بين الاتحاد الافريقي وجامعه الدول
العربيه والامم المتحده ستنعقد لمناقشه
الوضع خلال الساعات القادمه لكن كثيرا من
السودانيين يعورون اكثر على الجهود
الافريقيه فما زالت الخرطوم تنتظر وفدا
رئاسيا ثلاثيا من منظمه الايجاد وهو الوفد
الذي تؤخر معارك الاشقاء وصوله
تدعو قاده الطرفين للالتزام بقرار الايجاد
خلال قمتها الاحد الماضي بما يشمل وقفا
فوريا للاعمال العدائيه والسماحه بالعبور
الانساني غير المشروط والتعاون الكامل مع
مهمه قاده الايجاد عندما يصلنا الى
الخرطوم
وسط كل هذا يتطلع السودانيون لحل داخلي
فالمراهنه على الحلول الاتيه من الخارج
لها ضريبتها في النهايه
وينضم الينا من واشنطن
المبعوث السابق الخاص للرئيس اوباما الى
السودان ومسؤول شؤون افريقيا السابق في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي وابدا معك
بهذا الخبر الذي نقلته اكسسرائيليين بان
الولايات المتحده طلبت من اسرائيل
مخاطبه الطرفين في السودان والضغط عليهما
لانهاء الحرب ما هي الاوراق التي تملكها
اسرائيل في السودان ولا تملكها الولايات
المتحده
ان اسرائيل تعتبر كيان الموثوقا به بالنظر
الى اتفاقات ابرهام حيث كان هناك تقارب مع
اسرائيل منذ توقيع هذا الاتفاقات
وتطورت العلاقه بين اسرائيل
والجانب العسكري مع الجنرال البرهان من
خلال وزاره الخارجيه هذا من جهه وكذلك مع
جهاز الاستخبارات من خلال قوه الدعم
السريع وبالتالي قد يكون من المنطقي اشراك
اسرائيل اكثر في دعوه لتهدئه الوضع
المتحده هي التي وضعت السودان في قوائم
العقوبات وقوائم الارهاب والولايات
المتحده هي التي رفعته واعدته للمجتمع
الدولي والغت العقوبات عليه
لماذا تحتاج الولايات المتحده الى اسرائيل
لكي تقوم بهذا الدور
ان الولايات المتحده ليست تحظى بثقتك فتى
الاطراف تماما وهناك خوف من انها قد
تستخدم العقوبات مره اخرى على هذين
الطرفين الولايات المتحده قلقه بشان الوضع
الانساني
ووضع حقوق الانسان في البلاد وبالتالي هي
تستخدم كافه الاوراق التي تمتلكها في يدها
ليس فقط اسرائيل بلسم معنا تصريحات للتوجه
او نداء الى الامارات ومصر والسعوديه
تحاول واشنطن العمل مع اي طرف لديه قدره
على تاثير احد الاطراف او طرفين في
السودان في محاوله لوقف المواجهات وما
الذي يقلق الولايات المتحده تحديدا في هذه
المواجهه ما الذي سيجري اذا استمرت يعني
العالم مليء بالحروب هذه الحرب ماذا تعني
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
اعتقد ان هناك خوف اولا من ان تتحول الى
حرب اقليميه وتنشر اليها دول مجاوره
للسودانه
تعرف انعدام الاستقرار مثل اريتريا وجنوب
السودان هذا خوف كبير ولكن ايضا اعتقد ان
هذا ضربه موجعه لجهود التي تبذلها واشنطن
في محاوله لانشاء ديمقراطيه والانتقال من
حكم الشخص الواحد فالسودان كانت
بلدا في الكثير من الامل في السنوات
الاخيره امل بالتخلص من قيود الديكتاتوريه
وفتح افاق عصر جديد وحقبه جديده من
الديمقراطيه بحيث يكون ذلك مثالا للدول في
المنطقه ربما تحدثها وبالتالي الفشل في
هذه الجهود سيكون مؤشرا سيئا لما تبقى من
دول المنطقه
يعني كان هناك مؤشرات قبل ذلك في دول اخرى
والمؤشرات تاتي الواحده تلو الاخرى لكن
نشكرك شكرا جزيلا من واشنطن الدكتور كامل
المبعوث السابق الخاص للرئيس اوباما الى
السودان ومسؤول شؤون افريقيا السابق في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكيه
الى طائفه من اخبارنا الاخرى اعلنت سلطات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه اعتقال منفذ الهجوم
المسلح في حي الشيخ جراح بالقدس المحتله
والذي يصفر عن اصابه مستوطنين اسرائيليين
وقالت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه ان المنفذ من
سكان نابلس شماليه الضفه الغربيه ويبلغ من
العمر 15 عاما وكان الجيش وجهاز الامن
العام الشباك والشرطه الاسرائيليه قد
اعلنوا اليوم اعتقال المنفذ وانه اعترف
بتنفيذ الهجوم مستخدما سلاحا كان بحوزته
وفق البيان
اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فجر
اليوم سته فلسطينيين من مناطق متفرقه من
الضفه الغربيه المحتله وقال نادي الاسير
الفلسطيني ان قوه خاصه من جيش الاحتلال
اعتقلت شابين من مخيم عسكر شرق مدينه
نابلس بينما اعتقلت شابين اخرين من
منزليهما في قريه يتما جنوب المدينه
واقتحمت قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت بلده نحالين
جنوب غربي بيت لحم واعتقلت شابا قبل ان
تنسحب من البلده
افاد المكلف بالاتصال في البرلمان
التونسيه المنحل ماهر مذيوب في تدوينه ان
السلطات التونسيه اوقفت احمد المشرقي
النائب السابق بالبرلمان ورئيس مكتب حركه
النهضه بعد التحقيق معه ليله كامله وقالت
هيئه الدفاع عن رئيس حركه النهضه راشد
الغنوشي والسياسيين الموقوفين معه ان
السلطات الامنيه منعت لليله لليله الثانيه
على التوالي المحامين من حضور جلسه
استجواب موكليهم رغم استدعائهم من اجل ذلك
اعربت الهيئه عن رفضها ما وصفتها بالشروط
المخالفه للقانون والماسه بالقواعد
الاجرائيه المعمول بها واضافه ان
المعتقلين على خلفيه جلسه الحوار التي
نظمتها جبهه الخلاص مساء السبت الماضي
رفضوا مجددا الاجابه عن اسئله المحققين في
غياب محاميهم كما اعربت الهيئه عن رفضها
تزكيه الخروق القانونيه التي شهدتها هذه
القضيه من ذ انطلاقها وفق تعبيرها
هذا وعبرت الحكومه الالمانيه عن قلقها
البالغ تجاه تطورات الداخليه في تونس وقال
المتحدث باسم الحكومه الالمانيه
ان اعتقال زعيم حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي
ينضم لسلسله مقلقه من الاعتقالات لممثل
معارضه التونسيه والصحفيين والناشطين
تتابع الحكومه الاتحاديه بقلق بالغ
التطورات السياسيه الداخليه في تونس نرى
تاكلا للهياكل الديمقراطيه وقيودا مستمره
على مشاركه المجتمع المدني ان اعتقال راشد
الغنوشي زعيم حزب النهضه التونسي امس
ينضاف الى سلسله مقلقه من الاعتقالات
لممثل المعارضه التونسيه والصحفيين
والناشطين نحث الحكومه التونسيه مره اخرى
على التمسك بالمبادئ العامه لسياده
القانون والحق في محاكمه عادله وحريه
التعبير يجب ان تستمر التعدديه السياسيه
في تونس
قال وزير شؤون الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
بوزاره الخارجيه البريطانيه اللور طارق
احمد ان الاعتقالات في تونس بما فيها
اعتقال رئيس حركه النهضه رشد الغنوشي تقوض
مساحه التعدديه السياسيه في البلاد ودعا
الوزير البريطاني الحكومه التونسيه دعاها
لاحترام مبادئ وقيم المجتمع الديمقراطي
المنفتح لما فيه مصلحه جميع التونسيين وفق
تغريده نشرتها وزاره الخارجيه البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خدينا وصلنا لنهايه